good morning Brent how are you I'm doing
well Dan Wow five hundred million
dollars I'm just still Wow no okay do
you play how much you make in your
career um not that Dan um I don't know
exactly why i canno that I don't I don't
I know that at this point in my life dan
I don't have as much as I should who
should be going I won't show anything
mr. than that legend who should be the
highest-paid player in the game LeBron
James for sure I'm what interested no
question about that if this was an open
market like baseball and there's no
salary cap what do you think he would be
worth what do you think that he would
make I would think in excess of 50
million dollars a year given what what
he means to the league certainly to the
Cavalier franchise but what he means to
the NBA I mean I would think that's not
out of the question Jordan I think in
his last year got 28 million with the
Bulls so if I thought I was certain did
he get 30 did he push 30 the last 30 and
33 the last two years yeah why is that
holy crap right yeah yeah Wow 33 if you
prorate that with jordan yeah then you
know that's probably 45 minutes yeah
it's probably it's a probably past that
50 million dollar mark but yeah that's
that's crazy and Men Bryce Harper is I
mean the first part of this baseball
season has put on an absolute show for
the national so wow I was watching the
game last night and I see the Warriors I
don't know if the Warriors how different
they are without durant in there but
then you do get chatter where people say
are they better without durant I'm going
I don't know how people say that I think
they're different without him but
they're not better without him what do
you think of that topic yeah now that
they're definitely not better without
Kevin Durant and they certainly they
certainly have to play a little bit
differently when he's not in the lineup
but this is kind of the you know maybe
the the on
Spoken genius of how Steve Kerr has has
managed this season and how he has
managed in particular I think Steph
Curry this year and the way that staff
has approached the year with Kevin
Durant obviously when Kevin went out we
saw glimpses of the unconscious Steph
Curry and the scoring flurries and all
the things that we got addicted to last
year and i would i would say yeah i
played with guys who get addicted to
that feeling you know steph had that so
many times last year where he would just
start going off and of course the the
warrior faithful would love that and his
teammates would love it but he also
knows that league-wide people enjoyed
seeing those displays and then to come
into this year and to be asked to do
maybe a little bit less or play a little
bit differently I think that Steph has
managed the arrival of Kevin Durant and
I kind of said this after a couple
months into the season but it was
evident certainly you know in the last
half of the season when when Kevin came
back for those four games but Steve and
Steph Curry have managed that extremely
well and last night was just one of
those games Dan where I was riding back
in the car with with Marv and we just
were talking about what we had just seen
in Cleveland versus what we had just
witnessed with Golden State and how just
diametrically opposed these two teams
are right now at this point in the
playoffs with how they are playing and
how they're approaching games is it was
remarkable who do you like well I like
the warrior's spirit right now I know
that sounds weird I mean there's plenty
of statistical things we could go into
about what both teams are doing well and
what what Cleveland's not doing so well
but in terms of the competitive spirit
and where it is that the focus is for
Golden State right now and again this is
saying it with Kevin Durant being hurt
in Game two and plenty of signs pointing
from Steve Kerr that that they hope
you'd be ready for three and they might
not even have to play him in three if
they don't want to but the collective
spirit of the Warriors seems right now
to be much more laser focused on on what
they want to do and how they want to
play as opposed to where Cleveland
stands right now
there's a lot of a lot of bickering
going on and a lot of finger-pointing
going on and some petty things that it
shouldn't really be a part of a
championship run and we'll see if they
can massage those things away he's brent
Barry NBA on TNT analyst former NBA
player how many rings do you have I I
was fortunate to win two championships
in San Antonio Dan in the four season so
that was there so half the time it was
good the other half we were close all
right it is Kawhi Leonard a superstar
yeah yes see not easy to see I said he's
a great player he's not a superstar
because a superstar we know more about
them interviews like they it is just
that is he perfect for the Spurs
organization because they this is what
they do they would suppress this they
don't want him to be more than what he
is on a basketball floor well is it was
John Stockton a superstar in the NBA no
he was a hall-of-famer but not a
superstar okay so that's worse I guess
being a being a hall of famers who worse
than being a superstar no but Carmela
always considered a superstar I'm not
talking about his game I'm not talking
about Tim Tim Tim Tim was not a
superstar he's a hall-of-famer so now
we're talking about the commercialism of
your career is that more I mean would
that be more your brand because you ran
yes yes yes oh as as far as as players
if you were to ask of course coaches
players Scouts uh announcers all that
sort of stuff about whether Kawhi
Leonard is a superstar not the answer
one hundred percent of the time would be
yes violence are you ask a casual fan
because of the branding no then yeah
then Kawhi Leonard does not qualify yeah
and I sure I could say that because
Russell Westbrook is more of a superstar
than Kawhi Leonard from the standpoint
of you know his clothes that he's in GQ
he you know he's got a brand about him
James Harden is more of a superstar
because we know about the beard he dated
a Kardashian there you go that puts you
over the top apparently well there's a
lot of guys then
probably superstars if you dated a
Kardashian up can you win a championship
with Russell Westbrook no can't do it uh
especially in the iteration of what the
team represents now it's not about the
use of the talent or about how those
guys can improve but in that way playing
that way that sets it's not going to get
you to the that point no there's no way
that your team can can exceed what it is
that it then another team collectively
can do with five guys it's incredible to
watch it is just just mind-boggling the
things that Russell is capable of doing
um the numbers that he's capable of
putting up but the scheme for any
opposing coach dance to have a guy like
that play that way it it lets a lot of
teams off the hook quite frankly that
you just don't have to prepare for as
much when you have a player that plays
the way that Russell does and in that
vein for OKC right now it might be the
only and I think we've it's evidence
it's there's been evidence of it that's
the only way that they could win and
compete but to win a title with a player
playing in that fashion it it just won't
happen I'll leave you with this I know
you're a very good free-throw shooter
your dad one of the greatest free-throw
shooters of all time I'd like to get rid
of the high five after a free throw yeah
too much time well you should be able to
make a free throw it's not really a
celebration if DeAndre Jordan makes one
then give him a high five if he misses
one give him a high five but brent I
can't give it to a guy who shooting
seventy-eight percent or eighty five
percent well I mean what about just
support system dan I mean just about the
team camaraderie and that we're behind
you a thousand percent look we know
you're standing up there and those in
those shorts and your tank top and
everybody's looking at you and if you
make it I just want to know I want you
to know that I'm there for you that's
why I'm coming over here to dap you up
but I can gap you up if you miss one to
say I'm there for you not if you met
well I like the consistency maker miss
me too high five step in and give me
some love my favorite dinner on a side
note is the players that go up for the
illegal defense technicals and there's
nobody on the lane line they take the
free throw and a lot of guys do this
where they mimic the fact that there
would be guys there and high-fives and
they reach back behind them to get the
two that's always fun well when's the
last time you dunked by the way that is
a great question Dan I did it last week
I was with on my buddy who's a 67 year
old friend of mine that I work out with
like three times a week there's a little
gym in the workout place that we're at
he threw me the ball I went in there
they don't jammed it down 45 years old I
was like yes that hurt but yes I got it
do you think you'll be able to dunk when
you're 50 that is my goal I think I will
be able to do it i'm genetically it's
helpful that I'm remaining bone skin and
bones and I think at 50 I will get it
well we can all hope for that print
we're all counting on that and i'll give
you a high five when you do well I owe
you sweat pants when are you going to
give them to me here's a day it's funny
because they fit in my cross been nearly
rapper there in my closet to the left I
want to bring them to the studio I want
to come and see the salami homies in
their native environment and I need to
bring them there so maybe that can be
something that that could be worth while
we're in Los Angeles first week of May
okay well maybe playoff schedule will
get me there all right that could be
good that all you know what fritzy will
keep you informed and then you can let
us know your schedule would be nice for
you to bring me slam dunk sweatpants in
excellent i will we will we will shoot
for that damn tell up tell marv i settle
oh great to catch up with you will do
brent Barry one of our favorites the Dan
Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience